ونشير لهذا الخبر العاجل حيث اعلن الحرس
الثوري الايراني مقتل ميلاد حيدري وهو احد
مستشاريه العسكريين في الهجمات
الاسرائيليه التي استهدفت ضواحي دمشق فجر
هذا اليوم اشار الحرس الثوري في بيان الله
ان احد المستشارين العسكريين للحرس الثوري
الايراني في سوريا قتل خلال الهجوم
الاسرائيلي على ضواحي دمشق فجر اليوم ووصف
الحرس الثوري الهجوم على انه جريمه ويعتبر
انتهاكا مكررا لسياده السوريه كدوله
مستقله وعضو في الامم المتحده واكد الحرس
الثوري ان طهران سترد دون شك على هذه
الجريمه حسب البيان الحرس الثوري ما وصفه
صمت المجتمع الدولي امام جرائم اسرائيل
وانتهاكاتها المتكرره للسياده السوريه حسب
ما جاء في البيان
انضم الينا من طهران مدير مكتب الجزيره
عبد القادر فايز عبد القادر مزيد من
تفاصيل عن ما جرى
لافته حقيقه مريم ان ياتي الخبر معلنا من
قبل الحرس الثوري يعني في اخبار كهذه على
الاقل اخبار السابقه
الاخبار هنا وهناك
اكد ايران على لسان الحبس بانه هذه
الاخبار صحيحه ولكن اليوم
نرى بان الحرس الثوري وعبر بيان رسمي يعلم
بشكل واضح عن مقتل احد مستشاريه في سوريا
وضواحي العاصمه السوريه دمشق وهجمات
اسرائيليه هذا حقيقه
مؤشر لافت النقطه الثانيه التي يمكن ان
نتحدث عنها حسب الفهم الموجود هنا في
طهران والتصريحات السابقه للحرس الثوري
والحاليه فيما يخص موضوع دستوريا والضربات
الاسرائيليه المتكرره والمتتابعه على
سوريا فان الكلام هنا بان ايران لطالما
وضعت معادله بان الهجمات على سوريا شيء
واستهداف عسكريين ايرانيين ومقتل هؤلاء في
سوريا شيء اخر وبان الحاله الثانيه تتطلب
رد من ايران مباشر ومعلن
بالنسبه لاسرائيل اما طبيعه وشكل مضمون
متى كيف سيتم هذا الرد بطبيعه الحال لا
احد يتحدث عن ذلك ولكن الفم الموجود لدى
المتابعين في موضوع ايران
ولدها الرسميه السابقه تشير الى ان ايران
تقول انه مقتل اي عسكري ايراني على الارض
السوريه بضربات اسرائيليه سيتبعه رد
ايراني معلن في مساحه اسرائيل ولكن كيف
سيتم ذلك وهل سيتم ذلك هذا متروك للمستقبل
بطبيعه الحال الان يجري هذا الموضوع
والملف السوري يعود الى الواجهه سواء في
البعد السياسي او حتى في البعد العسكري
لذلك ايران ترى بان هذا الموضوع قد يعقد
الملف السوري اكثر مما هو معقد حقيقه خاصه
بان سوريا في المساحه السياسيه واضح بان
هناك تسخين لهذا الملف سواء على المستوى
العربي او حتى على المستوى الاقليمي
انطلاقا من ايران وتركيا وروسيا
والاجتماعات التي يتم الحديث عنها ويكون
النظام في سوريا جزء منها لذلك خبر كهذا
يحمل اهميه خاصه حقيقه من حيث التوقيت ومن
حيث المضمون كذلك طيب بالعوده للبيان وذكر
هذا المستشار ميلاد حيدر بدايه ما المقصود
بكلمه مستشار عبد القادر توفرت لك هذه
المعلومه وهل من معلومات عن كيف تم
استهداف هذا المستشار في الحرس الثوري
الايراني هل من المعلومات
كلمه مستشار عبد القادر بالضروره تعني
باننا نحن نتحدث عن ضابط في الحرس الثوري
ولا نتحدث عن جنود ولا نتحدث عن مقاتلين
عاديين او متطوعين او شيء من هذا القبيل
كلمه مستشار تعني باننا نتحدث عن ضابط في
الحرس الثوري يحمل رتبه عسكريه رسميه في
الحرس الثوري ولديه خبره عسكريه في مجال
ما في المجال الذي يعمل به وبان الحرس
الثوري ارسله الى سوريا كمستشار هؤلاء
داخل الحرس الثوري يقدمون على انهم ضباط
مهمين حقيقه لماذا لان لديهم خبره في
المجالات التي يعملون بها لذلك عندما
يتحدث الحرس الثوري في بيان رسمي بانه احد
المستشارين هو يقصد ضابط في الحرس الثوري
مختص بمجال ما
تحدثنا عن مكان الضربه نتحدث عن محيط
العاصمه دمشق
حقيقه في محيط العاصمه دمشق هو التمركز
الاساسي
لايران في سوريا في البعد العسكري والبعد
الاستشاري بالتعاون مع النظام في سوريا
عسكريا هو في هذه المنطقه
عبد القادر بمعنى اننا نتحدث عن دمشق
وضواحي دمشق هناك مناطق اخرى كذلك مهمه في
الوسط السوري ولكن التمركز الاساسي
للمستشارين الايرانيين ياتي في دمشق وفي
محيط العاصمه هل نحن نتحدث عن مستشار كبير
يحمل رتبه كبيره حقيقه
لا يوجد معلومات حتى الان تشير الى ذلك
ولكن اذا ما تحدثنا في مساحه ربما التحليل
والتفسير قليلا الاعلان من قبل الحرس
الثوري تسميه الشخص بانه مستشار الحديث عن
رد قادم من قبل ايران مكان الضربه في محيط
العاصمه دمشق يمكن ان يدلل كل ذلك وهنا
نتحدث بحذر
لاننا لا تحدث في معلومات حقيقيه رسميه
يمكن ان يدلل ذلك على اننا نتحدث عن
شخصيه وضابط مهم في الحرس الثوري بالمعنى
العسكري وبمعنى العسكريه كذلك